hey guys today is the first of June my
name is Justin to you're watching games
bunnies
first up Square Enix's active Time
Report show has revealed new details
about Final Fantasy 15 the video
confirmed that the game will feature a
character progression system that
functions similar to a skill tree it
also revealed that the game isn't fully
open world but rather consists of a
series of large areas that you'll
encounter sequentially game director
Hajime Tabata explained that despite
Final Fantasy 15 appearing to be an
action game in trailers it is still very
much an RPG that will have various
systems as well as difficulty options
protagonist Noctis will have seven
weapon types in his Armiger arsenal and
piloting ships is about to get quite a
bit trickier as you'll need to reload at
a checkpoint if you crash you'll also be
able to save anywhere fast travel and
buff your chocobo speed and stamina
Final Fantasy 15 is due out in September
of this year in far and away one of the
most boring stories that I've reported
on it turns a TA were concerned about
setting battlefield one during world war
one as they were worried kids didn't
even know the war happened EA CFO Blake
Jorgensen explained at the recent global
technology conference we were worried
that many of the younger consumers out
there didn't know that there was a world
war 2 or Vietnam so world war one and he
trailed off switching gears to something
more positive he added I think what
people don't understand about world war
one is the technology ship that went on
during the war people started the war on
horseback and ended the ball with
airplanes and tanks and battle ships and
submarines and that's a huge opportunity
for us to be able to do a video game
around that'll build one launches on
October 21 finally take to CEO stress
Melnick has had some interesting things
to say about GTA online and see our GTA
online has been really quite successful
with some believing that it's brought in
over 500 million bucks just from micro
trend
action even if that's the case the
publisher don't intend to support it
forever as Elding explained we do expect
GTA Online's results to moderate because
October will be three years since we
released it not only was it not our
intention that GTA online was permanent
but it's important that it not be
permanent we have to rest the franchise
at some point sonic has previously
called franchises like GTA red dead and
evolved permanent but not individual
gamers as for his opinion on via it
sounds like he's going to take some
convincing Zelnick said VR is way too
expensive right now there is no market
for a two-thousand-dollar entertainment
device that requires you to dedicate a
room to the activity I don't know what
people could be thinking he went on to
express concern for how VR will appeal
to kids who like to gain with friends
and perhaps more importantly wonderment
at how many people have a big open space
to dedicate to VR where they won't quote
crash into the coffee table let me know
down in that color box where you stand
on via and be sure to head to games but
we've got stories on overwatch and a sec
that is everything I have for you today
but do let me know your thoughts and
feelings on today's stories and I will
see you again tomorrow